and kind enough to take some time with
us on the pregame show Charles thank you
for being with us we miss you in studio
Jimmy wants to know what hole you're
on uh
17 part three and where are you playing
where are you playing sutian mountains o
that's a nice Charles you're you're a
Phils fan I know this but now with
Arizona in the mix where does Your
Allegiance
lie yeah you know I I'm really I'm in a
win-win situation not going to lie we're
looking for an answer Chuck we're just
looking for an answer Arizona Philly
there you go trying to play politics
already well you know Jimmy you and Ryan
Jason worth chase hutley you know I go
back to Smitty and John Kook and those
guys but I'm a die hard philage fan man
you know obviously I love Arizona I love
Arizona but you know every time they
show me on the Jumbotron in Philly
people sending it to me so I got to roll
with the Phillies smart
that's my man right there that's why I
used to have his whole uniform when I
was kid at the the the the Jersey the
shorts and and the shoes but but but you
used it you used Charles I would I mean
Charles was he was he was in shape that
must have been a blanket for you
then oh I love it I love it Chuck I love
it now let me ask you question when you
go to Philly uh where are you looking
forward to to the most
well iess the Philly cheese Philly
cheese hanging out the golf courses or
what Philadelphia has probably five of
the top 20 golf courses in the country
that's why I live in Philadelphia during
the summer you know my favorite golf
course in the world is s and Valley you
got aonic you got Pine Valley you got
Philly Cricket Club you got Philly
Country Club you got Maran so that's why
I live in Philadelphia during the summer
but man the weather's starting to be
nice out here in Arizona y'all y'all
going to be bre here playing
go Adra Charles thre out the first pitch
at Citizens Bank Park and I would like
your critique do we have that video
Chuck how do you think you
did well let me tell you
something hey man why do they have you
in the C uniform though little to that
was that was actually that was actually
in Chicago and Wrigley and let me tell
you something they told me before hand
you can't throw the ball high enough and
because you look like you going
down first I I was nearly as bad as
Stephen A Smith he was the worst
ever but you know what that man can't
even defend himself yeah but you know
what Jimmy you can't throw you can't
throw the ball high
enough you had a back catcher too you
had a back catcher he needed to block
that ball definitely hey
gota stay off Rizzo that's my guy
man hey Charles I know you I know you're
out there we we trying to pit you
against Phoenix and and um Philadelphia
in a number of ways obviously you're
going team-wise we talked a little food
but I'm going to mix it up a little bit
here what about the mascot you always
seem to have a little bit of interesting
battles and debates with the fanatic but
what about over there in Phoenix with
Baxter and the gorilla which mascot is
the one that you would be having go what
the fanatic ever do may not be the
fanatic after we watch this my gosh well
I I got to say this The Fanatic is a
living legend but I gotta go listen I'm
gonna go to my Phoenix Sons with the
gorilla The Fanatic and hey The Fanatic
the gorilla and the San San Diego
chicken chicken and Rocky and don't
forget Rocky and den the World Champ
Denver Nuggets I'm heading there Tuesday
to start the season those are the four
best Mas Scots in sports
history I'm sorry but I I can't I can't
I can't agree with you the Philly
fanatic is the best I've ever seen and I
I'm emphatic about it I mean I've seen
him batttle Tommy lass batttle players
batttle everybody strip in the middle of
the field get arrested I mean everything
I've seen everything from the fanatic I
haven't seen that much from any other
mascot in San us to go off Pedro San
Diego chicken CH you had right the San
Diego chicken was raw yeah but that that
that's way past I mean you were just a
you were just a baby when the San Diego
chicken P Pedro probably ain't been to
no other sporting events other than
baseball that's why he going with the
fanatic you said it that's
fact that's literally right Charles your
prediction for the series Phillies and
how
many well I think tonight is going to be
the most important game for the diamond
back they got probably the best young
pitcher going tonight in gallon I think
Philly Philly man when they're hitting
the ball they're unbelievable if the if
the diams backs got a chance I think
they got to win the game tonight but man
sber obviously Bry castanos OB I go my
man TR Turner when the Phillies are
hitting the ball nobody can beat them so
I think the game is really important
gall's been great the second half of the
Season I'm really looking forward
watching that man right there that Bryce
Harper hey out a Harper keep doing your
thing yes sir yeah born in October Got a
Feeling oober tonight's going to be a
good night thanks the
time exact it went exactly how I thought
it was going to go